كانما كتب عليهما الفرار فروا من هذه
المنطقه قبل نحو سبع سنوات نتيجه الحرب
التي شهدها جنوب السودان والان يعودون
اليها نتيجه الحرب جاريه في السودان وما
بين الحربين قصص تحكى
تحركنا وجانا في كمين بتاعه نحو المصلح في
عربيه لاندكروزر
والحاجات الكنا جايبهم كله ان شاء الله
السراير المهم منطلقات كلها
وحتى يتعرضنا ذاته يعني
الرجال نسوان
المعاناه هي السمه المتلازمه لهم فمنذ
وصول نحو خمسه الاف شخص الى هذه المنطقه
خلال فتره الاشتباكات في السودان يعيش
معظمهم من دون اي مساعدات
والله هذا من ما جينا هنا
حاجه لكن
الحمد لله
اخر تشغل بال الفارينه من نيران
الاشتباكات وتعقيدات الرحله فلا امن في
الطريق ولا طعام في هذا المكان
لكن تبقى نيران المعاناه اقل رحمه من
نيران الاشتباكات فقط ما يحتاجه حاول هو
الطعام
المئه من الفرين من مواطنين جنوب السودان
يتم على تطوير هنا في هذه المنطقه بعد ما
اجبرتهم الاشتباكات التي تشهدها السودان
بالفرار ولسان حالهم يقول
الطعام
جنوب السودان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات